[Music]
they've got style they've got sass A
girl's gotta have a couple of Secrets
and they've got spending power it's like
making a collage meet the old
influencers is this the largest hat
you've ever had on yes by far
proudly aging on their own terms it's
amazing what you can do at home
[Applause]
busting through stereotypes along the
way I believe that age is nothing and
attitude is everything
Vivian boyko retired eight years ago but
the Saskatoon grandmother needed a
purpose so she wrote a book taught
herself to play piano
[Music]
then came Tick Tock okay
my husband and I decided that we don't
want children
and we're gonna tell them tonight at
dinner I have three sons and I think
they thought it's just a phase mom's
going through she'll probably get over
all this Tick Tock stuff once she
realizes how hard it is to get followers
six weeks after Vivian created her first
video there was a million views and all
of a sudden there were thousands and
thousands of followers you know it lit
the fire
not only did she prove her sons wrong
the 69 year old is now a Tick-Tock star
so sometimes a doctor with her own Prop
Room creating videos that make people
chuckle all over the world
Vivian is part of the wealthiest and
most influential generation in history
baby boomers born between 1946 and 1964
and they're shaping a new conversation
about aging our age faces a stereotype
that we're done we've raised our
families you know now we're just gonna
sit in a chair and that's not the way it
is we're out to learn new things and
we're seniors out to have fun it's more
than fun in a youth obsessed Market it
makes dollars and cents this is sort of
like a marketer's paradise David
Silverman is a marketing professor at
Rodman School of Management in Toronto
he studies the buying habits of
different Generations what kind of
influence do they have well they have a
lot of influence in terms of spending
one of the things that people when they
get into their 60s they also have a lot
more time available it's estimated those
over 55 control 60 percent of consumer
spending and 60 two percent of total
wealth in Canada yet for every 10
marketing dollars only one is directed
at this older demographic they shop
online more than any other age group
they're not just spending on the obvious
their sheer numbers mean boomers are
buying more of just about everything
than any other generation they're
probably the wealthiest segment in
society right now now a lot of them are
starting to retire but they still have a
really big influence on how Society runs
even today one of the main reasons
they're living longer the whole part of
getting older these days is that if you
still have your health guess what you
have time to do things and to have fun
are they the same consumers that they
were say 20 years ago no I think they're
quite different first of all they're a
lot more active I think they're also
interested in doing things and remaining
quite involved in social activities and
so I think as a marketer you have to
consider that how are you going to
reflect people in that age group despite
their influence boom
boom remain in afterthought
pains targeting young people
in first place
Chief creative officer at cassette one
of the leading marketing and
Communications companies in Canada when
I started I was 26 Generation X and
there was an obsession with marketing
the Generation X and and how do we
connect to them a decade later the
obsession was Millennials now it's
generation Zed
and so this focus on youth Market never
really goes away
Sabah says while young people may be the
early adopters of the latest hot new
thing the older generation has most of
the money hands down they're the largest
economic driver in Canadian and U.S
culture he says smart Brands get the
message that it's not always one size
fits all you just can't assume that you
can use one generic way of speaking to
everyone anymore sister Madonna buter 86
years old goes for a morning run good
for you sister during the pandemic the
Quebec government had a problem this
whole Corona thing okay I'm bored in the
house and I'm in a house boy young
people were tooting out of Public Health
messaging
so cassette's team found a secret weapon
they used
to deliver the message and it really
engaged well with younger audiences
and I think creatively one it stood out
because he saw older people doing things
that you would see from younger
influencers on on tick tock
it proved to be a huge success
with more than 35 million views and 4
million likes
I think the other thing that happens is
this relationship between you know I
think of my kids and my parents and
their relationship and they will listen
to things from my mom or my dad more
than they might listen to me so I think
there was that connection point in terms
of creatively but also from an empathy
point of view or Connection in families
pop culture is starting to go beyond
stereotypes in books TV shows and movies
post more of my glammy grammy creating
characters that more accurately reflect
this generation
still burning bright Molly Johnson has
been part of the Canadian music
landscape since the 80s I was in a punk
band hanging in Kensington Market with a
pocket you know like-minded Annoying
kids
[Music]
from Punk to rock to Jazz can't take
that away from me the award-winning
artist has been making music for decades
when I look out into my audience I see a
crazy range of of Ages a crazy range
super young kids I'm always surprised at
the teenagers that show up summer nights
growing older in the music business also
meant being true to herself at one point
you did decide to stop coloring your
hair why did you decide to do that I
decided to stop coloring my hair when I
looked at the kinds of music I was
writing very authentic
and I wanted myself visually to reflect
the authenticity of the music what was
the reaction of the record company
fantastic in fact at one point our
beloved president said you're a legacy
artist and I thought what does that mean
and then he thought about it for a
minute because he's a very thoughtful
guy and he said I think it's because
you've outlived all those
and I went yes yes yes I have
we make it
she admits at times the ride hasn't been
easy in an industry always looking for
the next young artist we don't Photoshop
you can tell because my forehead's a
little shiny when you hit 50
you've built a career you've raised your
kids you've wiped down that kitchen
counter I don't know how many millions
of times you've been so focused on
others it's a difficult turning point
and I remember feeling invisible Molly
is in rehearsals for a spring tour in
France
she believes the key to her staying
power is trust and knowing at 63 she
still has a lot to say this is part of
being a true artist is to know yourself
trust yourself to move with change the
stories that you're writing the the
stories that you're listening to and
then trying to get into your music
always are going to be changing I
believe in staying fluid we're having
nothing for supper oh man again for
Vivian in Saskatoon life's unfolding
Beyond her dreams her videos have well
surpassed 10 million views and the
business world is taking notice of her
reach and influence she's approached
weekly by companies wanting her to
promote their products I think that
boomers are continually trying new
things we've come a long ways our
attitudes everything we do we've come a
long ways changing perceptions of old
age to a new kind of Aging this longer
lifespan means that people are going to
want to do more if you're feeling more
vital you're not going to sit around at
home you might travel more you might be
engaged in your hobbies this is a
completely different headspace than two
generations ago
foreign
[Music]